[Music]
fans who are craving
new music from adele might just have to
keep jamming out to 25
because she admits she has no idea when
it's coming
[Music]
it's been five years since adele
released a studio album
and fans are ready and eager for
something new
on saturday the 32 year old took to
instagram to express her excitement
over a new book she's reading by glennon
doyle titled
untamed stop pleasing start living
that's when one fan in particular
bypassed the message
and just straight up asked adele where's
the album
the song just responded by saying quote
i honestly
have no idea
in february adele performed at her best
friend's wedding in london
and reportedly told the crowd to expect
her next album in
september well fans ran with that
glimmer of hope
and five months later when adele shared
a photo of herself at a music festival
a fan commented quote teaser album's
coming out today
tell me now someone like you singer
didn't hesitate to respond with blatant
honesty
and a bit of love saying quote of course
it's not
corona ain't over i'm quarantining wear
a mask and be
patient adding a heart emoji adele has
been making the most of her time in
quarantine
and she's been more active on instagram
in june she shared this photo of herself
watching her 2016 glastonbury
performance
captioning it quote five ciders in the
next photo in the slideshow
showed her dancing in the exact same
dress she performed in
recently she shared this adorable pic of
herself
watching beyonce's blackest king while
rocking
a similar crescent moon look she
captioned it quote
thank you queen for always making us
feel so loved through your art
adele is not the only superstar right
now dealing with fans
pressuring her about highly anticipated
new music
rihanna is someone who can definitely
relate
i gotta ask you this because you know
not an interview goes by where i don't
ask you about the m word and i have to
for the navy and for the sake and don't
get mad at me girl
don't give me again ahead of her fency
skin launch in july
the 32 year old singer and entrepreneur
got candid with et's rachel smith
about her upcoming album r9 i
am always working on music i'm
always working on music and when i'm
ready to put it out
in the way that i feel fit it's gonna
come out
and you're not gonna be disappointed
when it happens it's gonna be worth it
i'm not just gonna
put it out just because people are
waiting like
it's taking this long i'm gonna make it
worth it
you